what's up you guys so before we start i
want to intro our guest he's the star of
million dollar listing new york and he's
one of the most successful real estate
brokers of all time he recently created
his own brokerage called sarhant that's
wildly successful he's done over five
billion dollars in sales and he also
invests heavily in real estate oh this
is going to be a good episode uh did you
smash the like button jack i smashed it
so hard hey everybody i'm ryan sirhan
and you are watching the iced coffee
podcast which has so far made 117
and 116 dollars basically yeah is that
good that's enough that's fantastic okay
great it's almost like you've been on tv
before sort of i sometimes i get the
numbers mixed in my head which when
selling real estate is bad but for this
yeah oh it's close enough exactly well
thank you so much for coming all the way
to las vegas all the way here for you
new york yeah this is crazy now what's
really cool uh is that we did an episode
together maybe like
maybe almost four years ago yes it's
four years like we hadn't even really
started youtube i don't think like maybe
it was just at the beginning days just
started right we just started and we
were in la you were still like a real
estate agent right you were working at
the uh
yeah yeah i'm selling sunset before this
is way before though before selling
sunset you're in one of his houses i
think yeah right it was in jason's house
yeah and showed up and he was like
working out very into his fitness
that's right and you had never met jason
offenheim before that day had you no no
yeah so i was nervous going into it
because i had watched million dollar
listing new york of which you're the
feature agent of the show and now you've
had uh what five billion dollars at the
sales is it more than that now in total
by the end of this year it'll be a
little bit over congratulations yeah
thanks yeah so what is these what are
these last few years been like for you
in terms of the real estate market in
terms of yourself are you investing in
real estate what do you think of the
current market right now
it's like oh that's a lot there's a load
on the line right there's a lot to talk
about yeah uh the last few years have
been crazy i mean you know we are
primarily sellers in new york but we are
global brokers you know so we sell
things everywhere we sell in florida
we'll sell california i've never done a
transaction in nevada but we like it
here now um you know we're kind of
across the board the biggest thing for
me though is in the middle of 2020 i
left the brokerage i was at for the last
12 years and we started our own company
douglas now we were at a company called
nest seekers nest seekers for 12 years
yeah small brokerage in the city
and i was just there for a long time
because they never needed to go anywhere
else and there weren't any other good
options
and before covet even hit i made the
decision that you know there are no
other good options so i'm just going to
go start my own thing and bring in a lot
of different verticals all the stuff
that i do we're going to put it all
under one roof
then covet hits and i
thought for a day or so like maybe i
shouldn't do this especially when the
market tanked 10 000 points everyone
left new york city and all the big smart
wealthy companies started furloughing
and laying people off left and right and
the real estate market didn't come back
in new york until 2021 really right
unlike everywhere else in the country
where the real estate market bounced
back nine days later
um and so we started we started the
company uh sirhant in september
announced in the wall street journal and
pulled everything in-house and have been
growing rapidly ever since um you know
we have the benefit now to a very very
fast strong real estate market new york
has got to catch up to the rest of the
country which is unique this cycle
because typically new york leads the way
this time new york is playing catch-up
um but next year will be a great year
because foreigners will finally be able
to come back right borders will open on
november 8th yeah
which will be a big big deal for us but
numbers have been awesome volume has
been great agent count's been great and
so things are looking nice and positive
for right now so what were the main
reasons you decided to start your own
brokerage yeah i have to say dude
learning from jason oppenheim running a
brokerage is expensive it's a very
difficult business model so how is yours
different and like jack said why did you
start it up so
we are uh if you want to call it this
we're we're a hybrid right so you have
two types of brokerages right now in the
world if you will you have the
traditional brokerage which which can be
mom and pop tiny right some small groups
or it can be huge brokerages but they're
big brand brokerage they give you your
marketing you get an ad budget and you
get a split that's it
but they own you and then you have kind
of like your shopifys of real estate
which are the exps the sides kind of now
like the keller williams a lot of like
the big firms where it's 80 20 or 90 10
split to the agent uh up to a cap and
then it's 100
and they're just kind of in the
background but there's no brand support
there's no marketing support they give
you some stuff there is nothing in the
middle that has a physical presence in
luxury markets which is important for us
because we sell in mostly luxury markets
that has an exclusive agency role that
then also provides a virtual brokerage
experience to agents anywhere on any
device with any client and that's what i
always thought would work really well
no one else is doing it so
everyone forced me to do it and so
that's why we're here and yeah it's
expensive but like running any business
is expensive but we have considerable
income from you you do education as well
so we have a big education platform so
we have about 10 000 agents now in 109
countries in a subscription platform
that sur that kept us going through
covid when no one's buying apartments
right we have the media business we have
the books we have tv we have everything
and the brokerage has grown really
really fast this past year can you talk
about the numbers behind the brokerage
because i'm curious what the investment
looks like every single month how much
office space costs you how many agents
you have right now sure what sort of
revenue you bring in if you could talk
about like let's say the splits or what
this looks like for you at the end of
the day
if you could talk about that
you want the nitty-gritty yeah clearly
um
listen the
uh overhead's heavy right the startup
costs weren't that crazy because we only
have one office and we will only have
one office per market which is built out
like a clubhouse so in new york city we
have a 15 000 square foot space that was
the old tommy hilfiger flagship store in
soho and it is where all of our
production team is based so our
education team space there and our
in-house creative agency are all there
and that way there's no desk hierarchy
because there's no desks and so anyone
who's licensed in new york city or new
york state for that matter can use that
space or not use the space the brokerage
is completely virtual everything's on
your phone every you use computer we
give everyone the computers they need we
give them all the platforms and
resources that they could possibly want
and lead flow right which is important
no other brokerage really provides solid
lead flow and we do that because we've
been working on the brand for 13 years
so when people think real estate
one of the things they think about is my
last name which is also why we we named
it that versus like sunflower group or
something like that yeah right
um
the office right uh pays i don't know
what we pay for the office pay like 40
000 a month for the office um overhead
expenses in general are probably like
half a million bucks a month wow yeah
that's head that's a lot yeah are you
ever worried that you're not going to be
able to make enough commission to cover
that or is there a break-even point
where like you got to grow to a certain
point for that to start
being in the profit i mean
our first year in the business we'll do
like 1.3 billion in sales
right so even if all things stop
the
education platform is a considerably
profitable business way more profitable
than the brokerage like education is a
profit margin of like 85 percent
we carry it about 50 because we just
want it to grow and we hire people or
they hire my team hires people like
every week is unbelievable like take
your time let's go find let's go that
but they really want to take advantage
of the momentum while it's there yeah um
and so that business does well and if
all real estate sales go away for me as
i think about an entrepreneur
diversifying income
the
you know real estate is my oak tree okay
one huge branch is real estate brokerage
and then there's many branches there's
resales there's townhouses there's
condos new development is another big
branch we sell towers right then
consulting is another branch you got
leasing landlord representation
consulting across markets
then the other branch i have is
education and sales training
right that's a subscription-based
business it's between 10 bucks to 25
bucks a month different courses are 4.99
to 1 000 bucks you can bundle them you
can do whatever you want and then the
pro course membership is really where
um
the business has really grown and it's
made the most impact on agents around
the world but it's also a big money
driver because that's ten thousand to
twenty-five thousand dollars per year
for people to come in and we have a
whole coaching business and a whole
mentorship program and those people now
do to kovid get to work wherever they
don't have to be in new york city now
right our head of that program is based
in denver yeah so how big is your team
when you reference them
uh that's an idea it
what we have three businesses we have
real estate brokerage right we then have
education and then i've got media so
i've got studios all combined on payroll
i have
just under 50 people
on pure payroll and that doesn't include
freelance contractors and everything but
when i talk about
brokerage team i don't know i just
divide that by three it's pretty sure
it's pretty evenly spread okay does that
ever stress you out having so many
different people relying on you
no i need way more people oh my god
there's only somebody
like you you you realize as you start to
build
people get
their slates get filled real fast and so
you realize like when you're small
everyone wears a thousand hats because
they almost have to but you're also not
producing as much as you do much later
and so then we get to a point where it's
like
he only has time to do that one thing
now because we do so much of it
so the other nine things he was doing
before now i need nine damn people to
come in and do that if i want to
continue to do them
and those are decisions that we have to
make all the time um it doesn't stress
me out to have the people because i'm a
very big believer like if you build it
they will come
the more people i have by default we
will sell more we will do more business
we will make more money like i just know
it and it's always kind of proven that
case like when i got my first car and
driver way before i could ever even
afford a car and driver in new york i
just did the math and made it real
simple for myself and said okay this is
what the car is gonna cost that's what
insurance can cost so average gas costs
will be car wash once a month let's say
and then a driver will cost this
what is that total all right after tax
for me how many homes do i need to sell
in addition to what i do now to afford a
car and a driver all right so i got to
sell three more homes per year on
average not that many
um but what is that going to do to my
time how can i buy my minutes back so
that i can
be way more productive so i'm not just
selling three more apartments next year
to afford the car and driver now i can
sell 300 more right because they go from
home office to mobile office to office
office and backing back and back but
first we have to thank our sponsor
attitude guys getting a good night of
sleep is so important if you're trying
to be productive so you've got to make
sure you have the right bedding to do so
and a lot of the bedding in the bedding
aisle is actually made of cotton which
uses up a lot of water and is actually
damaging to our planet attitude makes
bed sheets made from 100 bamboo and
because of that they save 500 times more
water than cotton and aside from being
great for the planet they are the
comfiest softest sheets i've ever used
seriously guys i've been using attitude
sheets for about two months now and you
don't realize how nice it is to have
good sheets until you have them
revolutionize the way i sleep and if you
guys are on the fence about trying them
they have a 30 day money back guarantee
so go ahead try them out for 30 nights
and if you don't like it you'll get a
full refund but i know you will right
now you can get 20 off your order plus
free shipping by going to etitude.com
iced coffee and enter promo code iced
coffee at checkout that's etitude.com
iced coffee for 20 off plus free
shipping remember guys that's attitude
as an eco attitude and with that said
let's get back to the podcast so what
are the things have you outsourced
we outsource um
that's a good question
uh i feel like i outsource a lot i i
leverage everything that i do so all day
long what i focus on brand sales that is
it you know um i don't do anything else
everything else i have done by other
people really um we outsource you know
coaching on the education side okay we
outsource like all those people that
people come to us and pay for it doesn't
pay for us to have those people in-house
right so we pay them kind of what their
fee is and then we take the va on top of
it from whoever is paying for that
service on the brokerage side we'll
outsource right now like
web service development stuff like that
it doesn't pay for me to have an
in-house software engineering team sure
um
on the studio side we outsource
not a whole lot really uh i don't know
what do we outsource
nothing yeah we don't outsource anything
i should i should outsource more
probably
um uh cody you're not gonna be
outsourcing outsource you
uh uh we don't oh you know what we do
yeah so our our app so the apps that we
create that team is outsourced again it
doesn't make sense for me to have those
people in-house got it that's been a
really difficult part for me is to
delegate uh jack knows uh but even
bringing on jack for me was was a
significant change because i was doing
everything myself yeah dude i remember
when you were doing it you everything
yeah you're like the ed sheeran of
content creation right have you seen
have you ever do a concert with ed
sheeran
yeah he is the most profitable musician
of all time why look at that because he
will come out on concert sell more
tickets than anybody else no band no
production one guitar and he comes out
he plays everything by himself on stage
alone everything is done with his feet
and he sets it all up and he makes the
music as he goes the most profitable
live musician in the history of the
world no band behind him he creates the
band if you you look like youtube ed
sheeran in concert
here and there he'll have
stuff on like the people
yeah we saw him at barclay center like a
couple years ago and it's like wait what
is happening he comes out by himself and
he immediately goes into it he's also
the most efficient performer if that
concert starts at eight he's on stage at
7 59 and you better be ready wow
you go to like you two or any other band
right up youtube and you're like all
right start today i'm gonna get there at
9 30. yeah yeah yeah
once and like it came out at like 11 p.m
i do this guy does not respect us
ed sheeran he's like two hour concert
two hours what i'm gonna give you
i like that yeah i like that a lot
that's good so that's kind of my
philosophy is that you don't need a big
team it's just like you could do most of
it yourself jack was a a huge help and
we wouldn't even have this con this uh
this podcast for jack yeah but uh even
hiring somebody else beyond jack jack
wanted to be two years he was doing it
he and i worked together yeah yeah
before even getting on a third person
and even then i was like oh jack do we
really need to why don't you just do
this we got a good thing going on and
he's like well we could try it but uh i
don't know i'm not finding myself that
much that much more productive with
another person i'm worried about just
creating busy work yes uh like you hire
another person but you only get two
percent more done sure uh versus just
doing it yourself yeah
yeah yeah so i we we definitely don't
hire for busy work we hire for specific
tasks that bandwidth does not allow us
to do in-house anymore so like what are
those tasks like i was saying you know
like adrian can only do so much on our
studio side cody can only do so much and
he might die soon uh because we really
overwork him
actually wait cody we just hired we just
hired somebody else for you what
yesterday yeah he joins monday
yeah uh someone else so we're really
beefing up that team cody's super
excited um uh because it's just the work
right but we don't we definitely don't
hire just to hire if i did that i would
have like 200 people on staff
um uh and we do not right we keep it as
efficient as we possibly can and like my
head of new development is also like our
acting co
um and she's also our acting sales
manager you know what i mean like we put
that all together um until we can grow
comfortably yeah i'm really curious how
you balance everything because you have
a family and how many kids do you have
you have a wife and does one pretty sure
i only have one one child yeah that you
know of yeah could be more though yep it
is it is def it is incredibly difficult
like i'm not there now you know right
i'm here i'm spending time with you not
spending time with my two-year-old
daughter that's a that's a conversation
that i have all the time like
what is most important what will be most
important in the future but i'm a big
believer and i think we even talked
about this last time like i i really
believe in manifestation and the power
of positive energy and like what i put
out there today is where i want to be
two years from now and if i don't put it
out there now and act that way then it's
never gonna happen or i'm just gambling
with my time sure and time is our
greatest asset so why the would i gamble
all right why would i so like i'd rather
put it all on the table today because
i'm 37 who are you 31 31 yeah
how do you 23.
get out
just kidding yeah uh yeah you have to
get out yeah i'm so sorry
like you
um you know do as much as you can while
you have the opportunity to do it you
know like i used to work seven days a
week every single day saturdays were my
office days sundays were open house and
running around my relationship time with
my girlfriend who's now my wife or
anybody else before or evenings i would
never take weekends rarely rarely my
first three years in the real estate
business i didn't take a single day off
now saturdays are data days you know and
with the baby and i want to be um and
it's awesome and then other times i have
to face time with her two nights a week
my deal is that i'm home
very structured so
two nights a week i'm home to put the
baby to bed if she allows me to but at
least i see her before she goes to bed
and that's monday through friday we
structure that on sundays what are my
two nights saturdays or data days one
night a week if we can is a date night
um so we just like focus and i don't
look at my phone
got it what's your like work hour like
like how do you how do you schedule all
of that
i um i have multiple assistants
um i have a traditional executive
assistant who handles calendar
gatekeeper kind of culture type stuff um
i have an email assistant who's been a
godsend for me for the last five years
uh he's like are these these are not are
they in-house or are they they're
in-house they have wow dude i get a
house but an email assistant you could
outsource that too
no not to i could i could outsource
admin tasks but someone who can think
like me write like me talk like me
understand
okay that makes sense right so like he
sits there i mean i get a thousand
emails a day that are not spam and so
email
is like the email is my life at the end
of the day which is really annoying but
it's also a non-stop kind of objective
list
but monday through
monday through friday my days start just
after four am
you know and i'm in the gym by five
o'clock otherwise i'd be a total fat kid
um and uh so i fight against that all
the time and then work starts at 7 30
and it depends on the day right now that
covet is totally over well not totally
but it is over enough in terms of how
work goes i'm you know there's work
events now there's dinner parties again
there's a lot of stuff i kind of miss
covet to be honest i don't know if we
say that the team gets mad at me when i
say i miss it but like
oh new york city during clovid everyone
left i could get from the upper east
side to tribeca in like seven minutes
right yeah no one wanted to meet
everyone just wanted to talk and zoom
and the only business we were doing was
really important sure you know it was
like a nice
no traffic dude no traffic it was the
same with l.a yes insane friday rush
hour it's over empty
every place all i got to do is pretend
to be a politician go on the news and
say you guys got to stay home and
everyone listens to you it's crazy you
should tell everyone stay home and see
how traffic gets stay home guys yeah i
don't leave i don't leave the house so
like i'm one less car on the road
especially especially in california not
there anymore so enjoy you're welcome
but first we gotta thank our sponsor
coinbase seriously guys this is a huge
one since everyone in this house and my
house have been using coinbase to buy
and sell crypto so you guys have
probably all heard the hype about
cryptocurrency lately and i get it it
can be a little confusing you might have
questions like where do i buy how do i
buy or what is cryptocurrency well
fortunately we are lucky to announce
that this episode sponsor coinbase
solves all of that coinbase offers a
trusted and easy-to-use platform for
buying selling and spending
cryptocurrencies and they support the
most popular digital currencies on the
market and make them accessible to you
and they also have a mobile app with
learning resources so you can learn
trade securely and manage all of your
portfolio in one place and millions of
people in over a hundred different
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets whether you're new and
looking for a way to diversify your
portfolio or you're just looking for an
easier and better way to buy and sell
crypto try coinbase today for a limited
time new users can get ten dollars in
free bitcoin by signing up at
coinbase.com
ich how much free bitcoin jack dude i
ten dollars ten dollars in free bitcoin
coinbase.com
ich guys this offer is for a limited
time only so be sure to check it out
today and thank you so much coinbase for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast yep yep yep but it's all fun
listen i learned early on like
i'm like you you know i wanted to do
everything by myself and
manage everything alone but
i had to make the determination of like
do i want to control everything and have
it be absolutely perfect or i want to
grow
and i could be the single greatest
basketball player but i will never win
the game because i need other players
with me
you know like lebron's awesome but he
also needs the other guys around him
otherwise he'll he would never win also
he would never be but what about the ed
sheeran example where it's like he's
winning sure he's the lebron james like
by himself correct i'm sure he doesn't
produce his own music when he's in you
know studios
he has a team behind
but it's also again it's a different act
sure like you have a different act from
everybody else like we all have our
different stories to write you know mine
requires more people yours thankfully
doesn't you know it depends on what you
want to do yeah um we were just with
supercar blondie alex herbert no way
cool right so she was in the office uh
new york and she has a massive platform
of following crushes it on facebook
i know dude she's growing on facebook
she went hard on facebook when people
were like facebook for old people and
she was like okay i'm going to show you
all the cool cars anyway like she is
you know she was like how much you pay
for this office that's really cool
because we're looking for one in dubai
um you know because we're growing i'm
like oh growing so how many people do
you have working for you she's like oh
the next year we'll have like 250. it's
like 200 and
what do they do yeah it's like you she's
like well i have me and then there's all
the other people and then we have like
all these people per platform
like tic toc she hires all these people
to do it so that she can just pump and
pump and pop and pop it's a totally
different i worry people lose their
their that like homegrown feel like i i
think with tick tock people love to feel
like authentic they just it's some
person with their phone even though it
might not be but then it feels like it's
just you and them and that's it yeah and
sometimes when i see some of these
videos i it's just you could tell
there's a production team behind it it
doesn't have that same connection dude
she gave me advice and i've told the
studios team as well and it's something
that we wrestle with i asked herbs like
listen okay you have a huge platform
right um that you started through social
i went the opposite way right i started
on television and then came into social
and have kind of grown it from there
slowly but surely like what's your
advice alex to me and without even
blinking she said raw
she's like stop producing if people like
see clean lighting and this that they're
gonna think that you're automatically
selling them something just go raw go
raw hold the phone make it shaky show
bad lighting and i was like really and
so we're still wrestling with that
advice
unique advice 100 i would do it that's
why tai lopez did so well in the very
beginning because it was just him and
his phone yeah and there wasn't a huge
crew behind like what he was doing i've
seen some of his videos and he literally
just sets up his iphone yeah and that's
it and like the obvious
quality yeah casey neistat but it worked
yeah it really worked for him even doe
brick i mean it's like you know these
guys kind of running around running and
gunning you know we've been with logan
paul while he's been vlogging and it's
like grab the camera run around you know
so it's it's and i don't know but you
also have to determine like what is the
story you're trying to tell what is your
market what's your thing like what are
you putting out there like i can't
iphone a 20 million dollar property to
her unfortunately the seller would not
use me you know but why wouldn't they
trust you to do that i think you have
good judgment so far you have a good
track record why wouldn't they say okay
you know what we're going to trust you
to go through with an iphone in this in
this house i think they'd say sure do
that um also
please do a full production because the
iphone's not going to show the lighting
the best it's not going to do the sound
the best we want a full-on beautiful
you know video tour yeah speaking of
which i want your opinion on producer
michael and the one did you see that
video yeah the 500 million dollar house
yeah we tried to get up there it's a
little bit in some banking problems
right yeah we actually did the house on
soma uh two days ago on the market for
just under 70 million that's like you
can like touch the one it's like right
above there yeah um house is crazy yeah
totally insane what is your what are
your thoughts about the developer going
so crazy with with both the expense the
attention to detail
i listen
real estate sales is all in the timing
and you can never predict it right
um
uh you know like belair road right we
did that property tour it was 188
million dollars okay fawaz
uh from saudi arabia came through and he
paid 94 million bucks for it and it was
fully done with the cars with the candy
all that stuff but he wanted something
fully finished but the house also sat on
the market for a long time and was
chopped in price over and over and over
um but then in palm beach in february
right lawrence mowens and his builder
crew years ago paid a huge amount of
money for a plot of land at 535 north
county on the ocean to build a massive
spec mansion all things included and
like palm beach which is only for old
people right that's never gonna work
they finish the house they tco basically
uh uh like uh at the end of 2020 they
put it on the market fully finished the
beginning of january for 140 million
dollars which is an insane price that no
one would ever pay in palm beach i bring
a buyer down from new york on thursday
and we bought it the next day on friday
and it was the sec it was the biggest
home sale ever in the state of florida
was done in february and so you could
say to them like oh
see good timing but we also bought that
deal because it was fully finished
didn't even have to think about it right
everything they put into it it just was
all in the timing wouldn't it been a
year ago it might not happen a year from
now right after kind of the coveted you
know buying season ends i have no idea
where things go yeah
but it's a total gamble yeah yeah that
was unfortunate because uh for those
that aren't aware this is uh what what
they called like the most expensive
house and ever made
basically 500 million dollars in bel air
this guy started the project 10 years
ago takes forever bought the plot of
land i think it was like 10 million or
it was it was some really low price for
this old decrepit house that kind of
looked like an old warehouse building on
top of this parcel of land yeah spent 10
years building it and i think he's
probably into it about 150 160 million
dollars yep
the banks are knocking at the door
because they want their money in the
house it's been a long time and listen
look but at the same time
look at billionaire row in new york city
look at extel gary barnett like 157 west
57 still not sold out he started that
project
11 years ago wow so like
this is one guy
banking it all on one house looking for
one person you know developers will
diversify that risk across lots of
different types of people but you're
also still going for the same type of
person yeah you know 157 like you're
gonna buy a one bedroom for four million
bucks yeah you know
are you ever concerned about more people
leaving new york because i think covered
really disrupted and
where people work sure and now that
people could work anywhere or at least
have an element of their business that's
remote people are leaving for low tax
states from california a lot of people
are coming here from both uh california
new york that seems to be where the
majority of like this community is from
yeah
more people moved to new york city than
left new york city in 2020 which no one
talks about because it's not a good
click-through rate for that story right
now are we talking about people people
moving to or just the population growth
of new york city like more people are
born there
that's a good question i don't think
it's population growth i definitely
don't think as many people were born in
new york in 2020 than they were the year
before
um uh but people moved to new york
because all of a sudden they had the
opportunity to so while people in new
york who are on the fence said oh this
is a good chance to go to florida or
nevada or alabama or austin texas
there's also a huge sect of people i
mean this is it was big business for us
saying
is new york on sale
like yeah we just sold this apartment
for 50 off like ah
this is a good time to move to new york
right everything's be fine
yeah i think i'm here everything's fine
and so a lot of people then came in and
now they're coming in in droves you
cannot rent an apartment in new york
look for a townhouse to rent in brooklyn
of which there used to be many right now
brownstone brooklyn there are zero
listings
i've never seen that in my entire career
people are coming in and they're renting
and they're paying double we just rented
a townhouse at 123 east 61st street
pre-covered would rent for maybe 35 40
000 a month we just rented it for 84 000
a month we just rented an apartment at
432 park avenue for a hundred and forty
thousand dollars a month just paying
that much i'm just curious what type of
person is business it is a total mix
people have money now in a way they've
never had the power like give us the
example of like a hundred thousand
dollars a month like what what type of
are doing finance finance different
types of industry technology okay right
that's a crypto these days
and you supported a lot of your clients
crypto people i wouldn't say a lot um
but i would say way more than
anticipated
right um and they're very flashy
because you're dealing with you're just
dealing with new money right right right
it's like it's kind of classic you know
you see when you deal with people who
worked really really hard for their
money and remember every single dollar
yeah
they are not flashy because they built
it through blood sweat and tears when
you're working with somebody who made
all their money in the last 18 months
you know like you're dealing with
someone who's like i don't know it's
going to go so let me put it into real
estate so we have a lot of that that's
actually interesting how have you seen
your clients change over time for
example like your clients 10 years ago
because you were still selling luxury
real estate got a lot younger so they've
gotten younger yeah and at the same time
like how their careers been changing
they are more and more part of the gig
economy
right people are not graduating high
school and going off to college and
w-2'ing the rest of their life anymore
at least not as many right
but my buyer base has definitely gotten
younger which four years ago was a big
push or three years ago it was a big
push for us to get into youtube right
was us and saying okay bravo is not
going to be
out there forever cable tv won't be
there forever right everything's
changing so let's get ahead of that and
my buyer
when they're 15 i want them to know me
so that when they're 21 or 22 i'm buying
their first place i want them to think
of me as their first choice and then
they'll be surprised when i respond or
someone in my company responds
and so let's go after that gen z buyer
really really really early even as a
company now like my future real estate
agent that i am working for today is
right now 17 years old
you know like i'm not building a company
for people that are in their 30s or 40s
right they can make educated decisions
and be adults they've done that already
i'm building a company for people that
have either been watching my content
since i was since they were 12. yeah
right or they're currently 15 and
they're thinking about what their life
is going to be like and what they want
to do and maybe they don't want to be
doctors or lawyers or accountants
you know maybe they do want to go and
take control of their own life and sell
something it doesn't even matter that's
why they bought shiba inu yeah now
available for public down below on the
screen now i'm kidding
but no i feel the same way i i've even
noticed in the whole finance space on
youtube uh four years ago it was really
predominantly stocks and you would go in
and be like oh this stock went up it was
tesla stock a few years ago that was
always that would be the biggest on
clicks yeah what did tesla stock do yeah
but now even now people care less and
less and less about the stock market and
more about crypto and i've noticed that
a lot of this is shifting nobody cares
what the stock market's doing anymore
it's like what is the cryptocurrency
market doing sure nobody cares about
tesla it's like what's the latest nft
yeah what did dogecoin just do today
it's wild to see this evolve and then
also see that like now i'm the old fart
when i come where like i'm trying to
unders i don't get nfts at all i i truly
don't understand i'm trying to learn but
meanwhile like the channels that are
kind of blown up now both on tick tock
and youtube are like these like 19 year
olds who are like yeah i bought this
board ape nft and this yacht club and
this thing and it's like i don't get it
yeah but but that's where the audience i
think is is beginning to shift yeah that
would be very cool to see it's trading
clout right it's trading baseball cards
it's um
uh and it's on your phone right and it's
gamified now
so like how do you gamify finance you
make it animated so that's what nfts are
right and so for a younger audience uh
who especially are playing with play
money who've been used to using play
money that has been totally fake right
or real money through like the
playstation store or through their
parents credit card their whole life if
they put money into cryptocurrency when
it was a joke and now they have real
money at least that's what it looks like
on their phone and they're transferring
it over to robinhood or they're using
coinbase like
they can now become you know active
quote unquote traders
curious do you own cryptocurrency yeah
what do you own i own bitcoin i own
ethereum i own a few other random things
i don't pay attention to it as much but
it's been interesting to play with any
dogecoin i have some
dogecoin how much how much
small amount i bought like five thousand
dollars worth of dogecoin that's like
when
uh this is the answer yeah this is
crucial no like at the beginning of the
year like
yeah it's not the beginning of the year
would be
really good though that would be
fantastic you must be uh
doing well with don't coin this coin is
fine for me yeah um it's not where it
should be though uh but also it was five
grand like it was just sort of like a
let's have some exposure
see i told graham to get into dogecoin
on a podcast because i told him i put
some money in yeah i put in a hundred
bucks and graham's like ah you know what
i'll throw in a thousand dollars guess
what this is when it was a third of a
penny yeah which for him is it's nothing
right and uh what would it have been at
the peak 150 thousand dollars it was a
thousand one thousand dollar investment
made as a joke on the podcast he's
betting so we were i was just talking to
uh my guy wall street bets and oh we had
him on the podcast literally yesterday
yeah such a cool guy to talk to you yeah
yeah he's been around but he's also like
so real and authentic you know and um uh
but it's what it is like people
people like to gamble they like to bet
and if it doesn't feel like it's your
money because you just got it yesterday
and you didn't have to go and like dig a
ditch to get your hourly wage and it's
just sort of showing up
sure i'll bet it on something else why
not yeah but it's been nuts the wealth
creation as you talk about all the time
you know in your content like in the
last two years has been insane like elon
musk is about to be worth 300 billion
dollars yeah first ever in 300 world
history yeah off of one company and one
stock yeah
well i think they're also valuing spacex
sure
yeah the umbrella like the guy you know
it's crazy yeah so what consists of your
portfolio do you have some
cryptocurrency like what percentage of
crypto are you in overalls five percent
10 i don't know do you do it all
yourself or do you handle it
no
like i know what i'm good at i know what
i'm not good at yeah and i don't wanna
be i would be i'd be too stressed out if
i'm sitting there like watching my stock
portfolio go up and down i just have you
know i just put money with uh i've got a
good wealth advisor team that i've
worked with for a while give them money
i'm like don't lose it
do you do you know where your money's
invested kind of but not really okay
yeah
if you ever want a second opinion yeah
double check yeah sure
i would love to see where it is because
if if you're telling them just don't
lose my money i'm worried about yeah
they could be doing bonds and stuff like
that yeah
no they don't it's not to sometimes i
wish it was uh safer
yeah like i i know they take enough risk
from what i can tell okay but i'm also
not a thousand percent it's where
we sell a significant amount of real
estate right and the businesses are
where all of my focus is and then i have
guys that invest money and make money on
it so what do you know what your like
percentage returns are annually because
if you do then we'd be able to basically
understand how much risk
i have no idea i was not prepared for
these
questions i just showed up
of course
i mean i think they've been great
returns so far right yeah do you have
just a set amount that goes in every
single month or how how do you structure
that portion of your portfolio it
depends couple years ago i would like
you know i would it was i almost viewed
it as like my savings account all right
you guys are going to figure out where
you're going to invest money and then
every month it's going to be a
percentage of earnings or it's going to
be kind of a set fee right or it's not
set fee but like a set dollar amount
right and so that way you're always
saying okay i'm going to put this away
in a way in a way over and over which a
lot of people have done with bitcoin too
right where they've just said i don't i
can't time it so i'm going to put 100
bucks a week right or a thousand bucks a
month something like that um but i think
like when i first really got started
years and years ago it was like all
right 100 grand a month like i'm gonna
put that in invest it that way i don't
spend it yeah you know and then as
business grows the dollar amount gets a
lot higher
do you base that on a percentage of your
income that month or you used to amount
at one point it was like 10
um and then sometimes it was a little
bit more and then sometimes less real
estate sales and you want to put more
back into the business yeah because i i
work for myself
right and so it's like am i going to
invest this or am i going to hire 10
more people that's always the dilemma
that i have to go in as an entrepreneur
do i put this into the stock market
where i'm not going to see it and
hopefully it gives me a return i put my
money to work because that's what i'm
supposed to do or do i build out this
new department in this new vision or do
i take the money i earn put it over here
and invest it and then go get a loan
because interest rates are really low or
do i do a pledge asset line through
charles schwab
and get a really really low interest
rate and just borrow cheap money and
then grow that way like there's just
lots of different options and there's
just lots of money out there how do you
balance that between real estate in
terms of where you invest your money
um
i invest heavily back into our business
okay i believe in the business really
really really strongly and i think we
can grow it to be something that's
incredibly huge and it's been 13 months
and so far so good so so far like it i
own a lot of real estate but it's not i
only own real estate because i see good
deals i'm like
i don't want someone else to buy that so
i'll just do it yeah you know um how
many good deals do you see these days
now because i've kind of stopped yeah
yeah in new york there's still good
deals you think so yeah and new york new
york is will always have inventory like
there's still 10 000 apartments on the
market it's a lot um but for quality
inventory
there's it's getting less and less and
less uh just depending on where you want
to go like if you want to buy like i
just talked about townhouses in brooklyn
like if you want to buy a townhouse in
park slope godspeed
you're paying half a million millions
over asking price right if you want to
buy an apartment on 57th street you
gotta cheat your pick right there's
choice because new york city is built
vertically so like here you got to build
out a whole new gated neighborhood um
which by the way how do i get back to
the strip from here
just go straight down the street it's
easy it's yeah on my feet
no wait can you call an uber here yes
when uber show up oh absolutely because
we were in other neighborhoods yeah and
uber's like i wouldn't come i could
drive you because i'm actually i'm
leaving yeah after this oh really yeah
yep if you don't mind driving with jack
he's totally uh he's a bit of a slow
driver but he'll get you there in one
piece have you ever ridden in a
lamborghini uranus before is that what
you drive
no i drive a lexus i was just curious
a rolls-royce colonist yeah exactly
the new maybach it passes
your podcast it's crushing it
questions for you guys so
what is your day like like what do you
what do you what do you do during the
day what do i do you wake up create
content go to bed kind of thing pretty
much yeah yeah now what are your
businesses now it's not uh well it's
five channels yeah so uh my main channel
the graham stefan show the iced coffee
hour this to family and millennial money
iced coffee air clips oh and the link
down below
the six channels yeah so what what was
the fourth one something family what
it's the family it's like a vlog channel
with like him me macy alex the assistant
yeah got it got it so you have six
channels and you're creating content for
all six channels every day yes yeah
between so there are nine videos posted
well if we're not counting the clips
channel it's eight or nine videos posted
every single week and i've been doing
that consistently for
well probably nine a week for almost a
year but seven a week for
two and a half years who who creates
most of the content for you who's
filming most of it
i film everything you film everything
yeah even this to family stuff no alex
films so basically this the family we
started because we wanted to just
monetize everything sure so we were
thinking well if i'm busy working how
can i make more money so i could film
myself working
and i could just post that it's like
behind the scenes like i really liked
gary vee's style just like document
everything so i figured well we're at
the house anyway
some of the stuff is i think is kind of
interesting so we may as well film it so
content yeah so our first video was jack
and i trying to make a thumbnail uh for
my video about buying a ford gt yep and
so we think well we may as well film it
and i wanted to get this really cool
shot kind of laying on top of the ford
gt like kind of like crazy and we got a
drone just like flying above because
yeah like an overhead shot and we had uh
our friend colby just filmed the thing
and we posted it and it got like a
hundred thousand views it was blown away
wow there's an audience for this so then
i just uh documented setting up the
aquarium
and uh that was another like 90 thousand
i was blown away and so we just kept
doing that nice so i mean things have
slowed down since then because
everyone's excited about like a brand
new channel but the purpose behind it is
once a week we could just film
throughout the week and just post a
video and you're actually sitting there
editing no no no alex edits alex edits
and then i go in and i do a revision and
then usually i'll make a few edits on
top of that and then we show graham and
then or we just post yeah i edit all the
main channel videos so everything you
see on graham stefan is that that's me
got it the graham stefan show that's
three times a week that's jack who edits
those videos okay so family is uh alex
how do you use alex got it how do you
determine what you're going to talk
about every week on your two minutes so
bad channels
that's that's honestly probably the one
of the most stressful parts if i knew if
if i had a topic i just woke up and a
topic appeared at six a.m every morning
yeah it'd be easy because then i'm like
okay i'm just gonna do that yeah once i
have a direction the hardest part is
picking a direction because if you pick
the wrong video
all of your work is for nothing you
throw off the algorithm yeah so if i
i've usually noticed where if i have two
bad performing videos in a row the third
video suffers by like thirty forty
percent like it's really good youtube
just won't promote it right because
youtube's like okay well their audience
isn't watching their videos now uh
they're getting few reviews twice in a
row that third v we're not gonna
recommend it as much because it's
probably not good yeah we're gonna push
somebody else instead
i could only have one video at a time uh
not perform well and if i have that one
video then it's so stressful it is
because then the next video has to hit
how do you know that it has to like how
are you gonna how do you determine what
you're gonna do just it's hours
it's it's honestly it's hours every
single morning trying to figure out like
i read everything on the news i see
everything on reddit i see i subscribe
like 50 different youtube channels i see
what people are talking about the
biggest thing that i look at is the
homepage of youtube because that's
what's getting pushed to you that's
their algorithm you're suggesting
content so i look at the front page and
i say okay well this is what's going on
now
are getting a lot of views right now i
want to talk about maybe i should look
into this wow it's gone up in price a
lot let me make a video about that in my
opinion super smart so it's stressful
but that's probably i could spend five
hours a day and even then i'm usually
texting jack to get his idea because
sometimes i'll i'll have this idea that
i think is good and i'll send his
jackets like ah no that's not that
interesting but because you're so in it
you can't really you don't really
realize that yeah so uh like today
there's no topics
if i were to post any video tomorrow
people wouldn't care unless really it's
about tesla or maybe shiba inu and
that's it i've already talked about
chibi enos so the only thing left to
talk about is tesla so i have to make a
video on tesla tomorrow if i were to
post anything else people do you write
this stuff up and you put it in front of
you you're just gonna you're gonna riff
it oh i never riff it yeah every video
is scripted down to the word every joke
that is like is supposed to be like five
to six hours a day thinking about what
you're gonna do and you write it out and
i write it out word for word personally
yeah holy mother i agree with you i know
what you're gonna say i agree with you
man you
dude do a lot i know but it's your voice
but like i am telling you we do a lot of
writing and we do a lot of live feed we
do a lot of webinar like all that stuff
and it got to the point where i was like
i need to find someone who understands
how i talk and how i think and then they
will script it and you improvise the
script right so that i so you buy your
time back i don't think i can see that
but you say that now but five to six
hours is a long
long time i don't think so i don't think
so i think with the nature of the
content it's just you have to you have
to have such an eye for like trying to
figure out what
you're basically a newscaster like we
talk to newscasters all the time they
wake up super early they go there to
figure out the news they work on their
reports and then they go live and they
tell everybody exactly what they've been
working on all day long yeah i don't
know part of me thinks that's the reason
why the channel's ground so much is
because i don't know because i've spent
the time that no one else would would
care like i do on on that sort of stuff
that's true but that's true for sure for
your big videos for the vast majority of
people they watch your content for the
transfer of education like they are
information they want to learn right
every video that you that you post that
gets like a million views is like uh
very education heavy right yes exactly
yeah they're learning from you yeah but
it's a structure it's the structure of
figuring out what what the hook points
are because every you can even revise
this to have a hook to keep people
watching so there's never a point where
i'm just like from start to finish
like one thought there's always got to
be and this was building up and then
this happened yeah and then i have to
change the scene to keep the retention
high like everything is thought out so
so you're going to do this for the next
10 years yes probably
probably i i don't know to this degree
i've talked to jack before about maybe
going down to two videos a week on the
main channel instead of three
uh it's spending more time on those
videos but
i know once i go down i'm never going
back so like yeah it's like once i
i don't know how i'm like able to do
this yeah and i know i'm gonna look back
and like i don't know how i was able to
do it because well now you you put the
responsibility on your shoulders right
now the audience demands it so now you
can't stop it you don't have to go down
if you outsource
yeah i don't i've tried i'm trying to
outsource my editing because that's the
only part where i feel where i have
probably
three to five hours to edit a video i
will tell you i would tell you though
like the edit is super important and
there's a lot of personality that goes
into it like i can tell the difference
um between who edits our videos
depending
within studios right because there's
certain people that understand jokes or
other people that don't certain people
know how to color you know what i mean
like everything's a little bit different
certain people are really passionate
about the content other people are just
i gotta get this done and so it's like
if you're gonna do that you just gotta
find an editor who like really again
just like writing yeah just like my
email management like you gotta get
somebody who really understands your
voice because that's what people are
listening to they could read all the
information you're giving them but
they're watching it for your voice
giving me the information so it could be
scripted it's just got to be in your
voice
correct but the other thing is that for
retention rates the video has to be
structured in such a way to keep people
watching so even though it's my voice
there is a portion of people out there
who will watch the video and if they're
not entertained visually yeah they'll
just be like they'll just tune out
even if the information is good how much
money you're making
that's that's that's what
no graham will tell you how much he's
making i know it's his career it's like
who else we were just talking to like
who's oh portnoy
yeah he's sort of poor noise like he's
so open about how much money he never
had and then how much money he does have
how much does he have now
like 225 million dollars i think okay
yeah so that's a decent amount yeah yeah
from selling newspapers you know it's a
cool story um can you give us a ballpark
about that the irs is not watching this
listen we we
i mean we clear
so we'll do gross like
i don't know 35 million dollars this
year
um uh and that is a good amount
okay and that i'm i take includes your
education portion of the business high
profit margins the brokerage is probably
a lot lower yep okay yep oh yeah any
advice what could we be doing better we
ask our guests this it's very helpful we
improve yeah i mean i've told you
already i would embrace leverage i want
to micromanage absolutely everything i
understand what you're saying with
that's why you've gotten to where you
are but what got you here won't get you
there that's why it's a phrase it's a
common theme i've never heard that i've
never heard you've never heard that no
i'll got you here we'll get you there
yeah i've never got you here like i had
to do the same thing because i would i
would take out every buyer every seller
and i got an assistant you know and like
everything was me me me me me all the
time and then like what got you here
won't get you there and so
you the the the voice doesn't change the
work doesn't change you're not going to
get like less busy your work is just
going to change you're just going to do
more and so you're going to make more
you know what else i could do though
it's like the exact opposite of what
graham thinks yeah yeah well got him
here will get him there
i'm still going there that's the thing
it's like i've not stopped getting there
yeah it's it's still going in that
direction so why why take a different
path when the one that you're on is is
is worse
yeah which is you know why what is it
like if the wheel's not broken then
don't fix it right right
um but anyway my advice is to leverage
what you've created okay right leverage
what you've created however you want to
do that and maybe it's not
doing things through other people maybe
it's something else that we didn't even
talk about today but this has been a lot
of fun thanks for having me one final
question yeah that rms is that is that
your is that for your name yeah ryan
matthew sirhand wow all right well
thanks for coming on yeah we really
appreciate it thank you so much make
sure to hit the like button subscribe
we'll link to your information down
below in the description thanks guys
cool until next time yes and then oh
yeah and then we'll finish